this is claudio sanchez singer
songwriter and guitarist for coheed in
cambria today while celebrating their
release of their new album vaxis act 2 a
window of the waking mind claudio is
reacting to just a few video game
musical moments both old and new
it's awesome
this place this is a better trailer than
most of the movies that i see
be sure to check out coherent cameras
new album as well as their upcoming tour
dates to see them in person all of those
links will be down in the description
but for now it's over to claudio
yeah i love it
it's it it's got me it's got my anxiety
up
[Laughter]
um i think it's doing what it needs to
do it's putting me in there like that's
the thing about like you know for me uh
you know i'm not
you know i'm not really uh
you know a professional like i don't
really like like if you were to tell me
to write a sad song like i could try my
best but like i couldn't like figure it
out like on the spot you know uh this
seems like it all works
oh when we get now we're getting metal
[Music]
like everything works like the music
with the fall with the foley sounds
it's great i i have played some of do
maternal i just haven't had a a chance
to finish it so many games i jump around
so much and then things just get kind of
lost
um
so uh
maybe i'll bring that on to her
[Applause]
[Music]
lockdown disengaged
you see the whole universe has a rhythm
well it's
kind of my pulse
and when i'm with her we sort of
become one
her music is my music
and my voice is her voice
that voice is coming from that demon
i remember this place like it was
yesterday
wish i didn't
[Music]
oh cool that's cool
[Music]
right on
[Music]
oh okay we can stop it
i think the concept is super cool
like
whatever the music is
like the concept is is pretty cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
like i really like that that's you know
like i think of guitar hero and and yeah
that serves its purpose it was a moment
of in time and was great but
this is way like i'd much rather have
um
a concept to play along
you know
i don't know how how to say this but
um this just seems way more interesting
to me and fun like i probably get into a
game like this
like i like that aesthetic i like that
spawn ish looking
type aesthetic but um
it's not the thing that will sell me on
a game necessarily i think that that um
that concept is unique enough uh i could
see how it could be challenging because
you know you just want to fire away and
get rid of the obstacle in front of you
but you know you have to play again play
with the rhythm of music and you know i
can see how that can get kind of like
frustrating but i think the concept is
interesting
rated t for teen
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well this is great
[Applause]
this is my favorite one
i'm totally immersed
[Laughter]
fantastic
rock band not necessary you know it
definitely has a place
um you know watching my
wife and friends like trying to play
that song you know people don't
understand it's like
when i sing the song live i'm not
singing it as i sang it on the record
so i'm clearly not going to get a pure
hundred
but that is uh
that is what was expected of me and i
have fond memories of of that and being
a part of that you know that's funny
because i think that that's the firs
that was the beginning i don't think we
even knew it was a thing or what it was
it's just
hey here's this game and you're going to
have a controller that's a guitar and
drums and yada yada yada and
you know
your song's going to get licensed to it
and it's like yeah cool i mean
i wanted people to hear the song for
sure
um but uh it's funny like that's you
know that song's a
huge part of or that game is a huge part
of kohi's dna because there are times
where you know
a lot of fans that were introduced um by
whether it's the p like the psp back in
the day uh the playstation portable had
a demo disc that came with it and us
being on
sony they had um on the demo disc they
had the blood red summer video so i've
had fans come up and say i've been
introduced to your band by playing the
psp or i've been introduced to your band
because i know your song from rock band
or it's wild um
but at the time i don't think it was the
animal it became
because i think it was i think it was
it's its first
um incarnation when we were asked so we
had no idea
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's awesome
this place this is a better trailer than
most of the movies that i see on
sick
i think that was
that was awesome
it's great i like wolfenstein i like the
title i like
play three out of the four new ones
you know uh i thought that was a good
use of of the animals house of the
rising sun
you know
doing it uh you know bringing that in
and out with the uh
with the um
with the more uh advanced nine inch
nails ish like industrial kind of bed in
the middle
um i think that might have been my
favorite of all of them that we've seen
so far and again it plays it ever it
feels right i mean we're not talking
like a wes anderson movie you know it's
like uh
you know that's what it is what it is
and um
and uh i enjoyed it
i think i know this yeah
[Music]
it's nice
you know it definitely plays on that
lonely
open
expansive vibe i yeah i like it
i mean i also really like these games
again i don't i can't remember if i
finished this or not i don't think i did
but red dead too
i think there's a moment like that in
the new red dead but i did spend a lot
of time with
with two because it came out at the
perfect time like the band was about to
go on tour and it gave me something to
do so i bought it brought the system out
with me um at the time as a ps4 so now
i'm also like
i'm a fan of like the sergio leone like
spaghetti western so like i mean i'm
into it so
um
i don't think you could do any wrong
aside from like if you decided to put
some of the music from clip you played
before if you decided to put that in red
dead redemption then maybe i'd be like
yeah it doesn't really fit with uh with
what i'm viewing
what they selected for that moment i
think was uh was perfect so
once again a big thanks to claudio for
joining us on this video be sure to
check out the release of vaxxers2 like
the video if you enjoyed subscribe for
more like this and be sure to let us
know in the comments below who or what
you'd like to see featured next
[Music]